[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren zu einer spezialausgabe von fiel
nach 85 köpfe fünf meinungen seit sieben
tagen wütet putins krieg hunderttausende
menschen fliehen und die ukrainische
soldaten kämpfen tapfer gegen die
russische armee wie wahrscheinlich ist
es dass putin auf dauer die gesamte
ukraine gesetzt dieser sich deutschland
verhalten und wer hat putin eigentlich
so groß gemacht darüber möchte ich mit
meinen gästen diskutieren brigadegeneral
ag erich fahrt er war von 2006 2013
gruppenleiter im bundeskanzleramt
sekretär des bundessicherheitsrates und
militär politischer berater der
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel heute ist
der international gefragt der
sicherheitsexperte und unternehmer neben
ihnen der verantwortliche bild politik
redakteur julian repke eine freundin
sagt heute zu mir am telefon berlin jan
rotter über die ukraine und russland
spricht hängig an seinen lippen wenige
haben solche tiefgehende kenntnisse wie
er neben mir zumindest digital der
stellvertretende bild chefredakteur und
führte nach acht gastgeber paul
ronzheimer der uns live aus kiew
zugeschaltet ist und die ganze sendung
bei uns bleiben wird neben ihm sitzt
ludmilla maniacs sie ist
wissenschaftliche mitarbeiterin am
institut für europäische politik und
setzt sich seit 2000 16 die deutsch
ukrainischen beziehungen haben sie wohl
im osten der ukraine geboren und ist
2010 nach deutschland gegangen ihre
eltern und cousinen sind noch in der
ukraine lassen sie uns keine zeit mehr
verlieren und direkt zu points haben
nach kiew schalten der uns von seinem
tag und den bedrückten den geschehnissen
in kiew berichten wird
ja für den tagen danach ich schätze dass
das ich heute abend wieder bei nach acht
sein kann um zu berichten was hier was
in diesen momenten in kiew in der
hauptstadt passiert vor einer halben
stunde wieder sirenenalarm und es ist
das erste mal dass wir explosionen
relativ in der nähe des zentrums gehört
haben nicht zu vergleichen mit der
dramatik die ist interaktiv im osten der
stadt gab wo bewiesenermaßen
streumunition eingesetzt wurde vor
anderthalb stunden bin ich wieder
gekommen von einem geheimen ort wo ich
die klitschko brüder erneut treffen
konnte beide sehr mitgenommen
teilweise nur ein bis zwei stunden
geschlafen und sie sagen der angriff auf
kiew kann jede minute beginnen also alle
rechnen hier damit das ist so dramatisch
dass ist so schlimm werden kann auch wie
im osten der stadt wo ein feuerball
regelrecht durch die stadt sich den weg
gewalzt hat heute war ich auf der straße
unterwegs ich war in einem jahr bunker
muss ich sagen in einem krankenhaus
bunker wo säuglinge geboren wurden heute
alleine sechs babys und wenn man das
sieht diese babys die geboren werden in
einen krieg in einem land das in einem
krieg steht wo menschen sterben da
können nur die tränen kommen und genau
so ging's mir in der situation in einem
weiteren bunker in der tram wo die
menschen saßen einer hatte einen
besonders lieben rund dabei den ich
streicheln konnte und die gesagt hat ich
bin hier seit sieben tagen ich weiß
nicht wie lange ich noch hier bin aber
ich habe angst weil ich gesehen habe wie
die rakete eingeschlagen ist am tv turm
es sieht danach aus dass das was wir
hier erlebt haben in der hauptstadt erst
der anfang von putins kroll taten ist
wow du bist ja schon seit tagen sie ist
genau was da passiert vielleicht kannst
du noch mal überlegen wie diese diese
situation dass man kurz davor ist
eingekesselt zu werden also wirklich
dass wir wissen dass im norden der stadt
stehen irgendwie ein 60 kilometer langer
konvoi der russischen armee im osten
wissen wir jetzt dass mittlerweile ganz
nah am flughafen borispol dort auch die
russische einheiten vor gefahren sind
ist kannst du das vielleicht noch mal
erklären wie ist das psychologisch nicht
nur für dich sondern auch für die
menschen dort überhaupt auszuhalten dass
man weiß da kommen wirklich feindlich
gesonnene menschen auch ein zu von einer
armee deren machthaber gesagt hat die eu
keine existiert überhaupt nicht die
gibt's gar nicht die leute dort gibt es
überhaupt nicht das ist kein staat das
sind nur leute die die irgendwie ja
irgendwas dazwischen sind und die zu uns
kommen müssen kannst du uns noch mal
noch mal sagen wie diese diese lage ist
von den menschen denn wir wissen ja von
den drei millionen etwas schief da ist
nicht die hälfte geflogen da sind nicht
mal 20 prozent gefunden also die meisten
immer noch da und warten oder
julian das ist auch das für mich
überraschende muss ich sagen gestern und
auch heute habe ich vor den supermärkten
lange schlangen gesehen da wir teilweise
jetzt schon rationiert alles ist nicht
mehr verfügbar es gibt logistische
probleme und wenn man mit den menschen
spricht und ich frage sie warum fliegt
ihr nicht ihr seht doch die
panzerkolonne die auf diese stadt
zurollt gehört doch von den schweren
waffen die eingesetzt werden dort im
osten bereits dann sagen sie gucken mich
fast ein bisschen verständnislos an und
sagen warum putin greift uns an und ich
soll mein land verlassen putin greift
uns an und ich soll fliehen putin greift
uns an und wir sollen uns ergeben das
ist genau die stimmung die es hier in
der ukraine gibt und was wir vielleicht
in deutschland nicht so fassen können
ist dieser patriotismus und der sehr
positiv ist muss ich sagen oder
zumindest auf mich diesen eindruck macht
diese geschlossenheit im land dass man
auch nach sieben jahren arbeit an dieser
demokratie nach dem majdan nicht unter
putins york will man hat angst davor man
will es nicht man will richtung westen
orientiert bleiben in der ganz großen
mehr und da nimmt man sogar in kauf dass
man eingekesselt werden kann gehören das
hier nicht mehr durchkommt dass man hier
ist aber dass man in der ukraine bleiben
kann in der heimat herrscht schon vor
der sendung zu mir gesagt sie wären auch
erwachsene gerne eine frage stehe auch
sehr gerne und sehr gerne herr anzahl
wie ist denn die die lage so insgesamt
was sagen die ukraine was erwarten die
was die russen in kiew machen werden
nicht denn die stadt ist ja tatsächlich
so gut wie
umzingelt und sie müssen jetzt natürlich
irgendwas machen den blick auf die
politische führung dies militärische
hauptquartier die kommunikationszentrale
wissen sie da haben sie da mehr darüber
erfahren
also kiew rechnet mit einem angriff wie
er aktiv passiert ist oder in anderen
städten tatsächlich hatte man gestern
bereits angekündigt das war eine
offizielle ankündigung aus russland dass
man das geheim dienstgebäude angreifen
würde da hat man die menschen
aufgefordert aus dem bereich diesem
bereich bereits zu verlassen und man
rechnet damit dass ja genau das nämlich
passiert neben dem fernsehturm auch die
kommunikation angegriffen werden kann
oder angegriffen wird mich wundert er
dass das noch nicht passiert ist
vielleicht können sie mit ihrem
militärischen hintergrund da etwas zu
sagen
ob das vielleicht doch komplizierter ist
als man denkt weil ich hätte erwartet
dass russland das schon geschafft
schaffen würde das zu tun aber
gleichzeitig stelle ich mir die frage
überschätzen wir eventuell alle die
russische armee und nicht nur putin
strategie sondern auch das was die
russische armee wirklich will natürlich
muss man aufpassen mit den bildern und
videos die wir auch von ukrainischer
seite bekommen denn die zeigen sich
natürlich im lichte immer auch als
sieger und nutzen da sozusagen in ihrem
sinne auch eine propaganda und dennoch
sieht man ja an vielen kleineren orten
das ist ja auch was wir häufig vergessen
es geht ja nicht ausschließlich um kiew
sondern der krieg wütete aktiv in mario
pohl in odessa in vielen vielen noch
kleineren städten der ukraine und da
sieht man videos wie sich ukrainische
zivil vor panzer stellen wie sie auch
mit russischen soldaten ganz normal
reden und die hoffnung ist dass diese
hoffnung hat auch die politische führung
der ukraine dass die soldaten putins
nicht bereit sind bis zum äußersten zu
gehen zumindest in den städten und die
befehle umzusetzen aber wahrscheinlich
ist dass er etwas illusorisch ist ja ich
glaube schon nach herrnsheim also ich
rein militärisch betrachtet glaube ich
werden sie alles tun um straßen und
häuser kämpfe zu vermeiden
aber das ist in kiew nicht so einfach da
müssen sie eigentlich rein weil dort die
politische leitung sitzt nicht das
militärische hauptquartier die
kommunikation zentralen wenn sie die
intakt lassen dann denken sie vielleicht
auch weiter schon das weiß man nicht
aber insgesamt schließen sie die großen
städte tendenziell eher eingehen nur
nadelstich artig rein also geheimdienst
hauptquartier sicherlich
polizeihauptquartier sowas sind
natürlich ziele aber wollen natürlich so
einen abnutzungskrieg im urbanen umfeld
vermeiden weil sie damit auch nicht
schnell raum gewinnen der angriff der
russen ist ja auch langsamer geworden
also im norden jedenfalls das staut sich
ja alles nördlich von kiew aber im süden
sieht es doch wieder anders aus also da
sind sie eher richtung oder unterwegs
und dann die landverbindung können in
den bombers was ich so höre scheint die
fast schon etabliert zu sein zu stehen
er fahrt eine rückfrage sehen sie sehen
sie irgendeine chance
sehen sie irgendeine chance
entschuldigung für die unterbringung sie
irgendeine chance auch wenn es nur eine
einprozentige ist für die ukraine
ja das ist jetzt die frage also rein
militärisch gesehen
ich habe bei vw nicht ja eben auch
darüber gesprochen wer also dass das ein
konventionelle übergewicht der russen
ist enorm natürlich nicht aber
städtisches gebiet eignet sich auch gut
zur verteidigung hat aber den nachteil
dass die zivilbevölkerung involviert ist
von vornherein es ist ja leicht
innstädter reinzukommen die amerikaner
im irak zum beispiel
bagdad yaman war schnell drin aber das
problem war hinterher oder die israelis
auch in den 80er jahren waren sehr
schnell in beirut aber
über frieden das land unter kontrolle zu
halten das hat ihn wahnsinnig probleme
gemacht und wenn es den russen nicht
gelingt möglichst schnell sag ich mal
die entscheidung herbeizuführen wenn es
also richtung abnutzungskrieg geht
dann ist das ein hoher stressfaktor für
die russen weil ich glaube das kann er
auf dauer nicht lange durchhalten
politisch auch weil putin steht schon
ziemlich unter druck würde ich sagen
wenn man alles zusammennimmt an dieser
stelle will ich eine frau wenig in die
runde reinholen frau meine kann es
vielleicht auch eine taktik sogar von
herr putin sein da sie sehen gar nicht
überrascht dass er nicht so schnell
vorankommt also jetzt von anfang an
geplant hatte sofort zu gehen könnte das
auch eine erklärung sein warum das
vorrücken sowie sagen wir fast langsam
erscheint für die stärke der russischen
armee ich glaube wir haben uns einfach
mit dem gedanken ab gewöhnen dass wir
das die russische armee die fast einer
den größten armee in europa ist und ich
glaube wir haben auch dafür viel zu tun
mit der propaganda und desinformation
und am 24
februar heißt das wir kriegen bekannte
gang was nicht persönlich überrascht hat
aber ich möchte betonen ich bin keine
militärexperten dass dieser angriffe an
verschiedenen orten stattfand und wenn
man dann mit den menschen gesprochen hat
gab es an manchen orten eigentlich nicht
so große explosionen aber halt diese
tatsache wenn man die karte dann sich
angeschaut hat das war schon sehr
überwältigend und ich glaube am ersten
tag wollte schon boden einfach den
eindruck auch im westen erzeugen wir
sind hier und wir schaffen da sehr
schnell einfach um diese macht nach
außen zu kommunizieren und in dem krieg
was wir jetzt in der ukraine erleben
vergessen wir immer das ist eine hybride
kriegsführung und wir haben heutzutage
mit einem krieg das ist schon ein
präsident loser krieg die aus
verschiedenen dimensionen besteht einmal
diese militärische dimension
die zweite dimension das ist cyber
angriffe die vorher stattfanden aber
auch
jetzt weiterhin stattfinden und die die
dritte dimension das ist propaganda und
desinformation und bei der propaganda
ich glaube diese information was wir
unterschätzen das ist nämlich dass die
desinformation propaganda schaffen die
möglichkeit einfach eine parallele welt
zu schaffen und das ist eine der größten
herausforderungen
mit der wir in unsere zeit zu tun haben
auf die drei dimensionen des russischen
angriffskrieges kommen wir auch nachher
nochmal in etwas länger zu sprechen
jetzt möchten wir kurz zu meint bzw zu
seiner these denn ich habe heute keine
mitgebracht wir wollen lieber die
ansicht von philipp verfahren die
meinungs- chef vom bild der in lemberg
ist und da auch schon seit mehreren
tagen jetzt über einer woche berichtet
philipp die allererste frage vor der
these natürlich ja wie geht es dir in
dem werk
haben mir geht es gut lemberg ist nach
wie vor die sicherste stadt in der
ukraine wir haben zwar jetzt gerade
wieder ein luftalarm will bislang ist
überhaupt nichts passiert zum glück wir
erleben hier weniger den krieg als die
folgen dieses krieges sind
hunderttausende menschen die hier
ankommen aus dem osten des landes aus
kirchheimer gerade ist das sind menschen
die schwer traumatisiert sind die zum
teil am ganzen körper zitternd und
weinend wenn sie herankommt die manchmal
eine nacht bleiben und dann aber auch
nicht länger hier in lemberg bleiben
möchten sondern sofort zum bahnhof gehen
zum busbahnhof und einfach nur versuchen
heraus zu kommen weil sie immer noch so
unter schock stehen von dem was die
russen pro russischen truppen angetan
haben und du hast uns heute abend auch
eine these mitgebracht wo du sagst die
muss diskutiert werden im deutschen
fernsehen
ganz genau ich bin ihr wie gesagt in
lemberg ich sehe jeden tag was dieser
krieg mit den menschen macht und mich
hat das in den ersten tagen erstmal sehr
positiv überrascht wie in deutschland
plötzlich menschen viele politiker
aufgewacht sind aber einer scheint noch
immer nicht aufgewacht zu sein und das
ist kein spd politiker kein
linkspolitiker keine fdp politiker
sondern dass es sachsens
cdu-ministerpräsident
michael kretschmer der seit jahren ein
sehr enges verhältnis zum müller hat und
ich habe gehofft dass er jetzt zumindest
endlich versteht wie falsch das war was
für eine fehlannahme das war dass man
mit putin irgendeiner art von
partnerschaft haben kann aber nein er
spricht weiterhin von einer engen
partnerschaft mit russland erfordert im
westen dazu auf in diesem konflikt auch
verbal abzurüsten er fordert im westen
dazu auch dass man den konflikt nicht
weiter anheizt
ich wäre es absolut unbegreiflich wie
ein deutscher politiker auch der
bundesregierung damit einen vorwurf
machen kann während der russische
truppen sind die gerade hf in schutt und
asche legen in kiew umzingelt haben die
tausende ukrainischer zivilisten getötet
haben wir sind gerade in deutschland
dabei die causa schröder endlich
aufzuarbeiten wir sind dabei uns
anzuschauen was manuela schwesig die
ministerpräsidentin der spd in
mecklenburg vorpommern getan hat aber
ich würde auch mittlerweile sagen die
cdu hat in form von michael kretschmer
ein ganz ernsthaftes putin problem das
es zu lösen gilt
julian kaum jemand cover die politik und
vor allem ihr auch die konflikte so sehr
wie du siehst du das auch so hat die cdu
an putin problem ich glaube die cdu hat
einen putin problem aber dieses dieses
problem geht weiter und ich finde es
sehr wichtig überhaupt was was philipp
gerade gesagt hat wir gucken beim thema
pro russisch oder pro krimi gucken wir
immer in deutschland auf afd und linke
die ideologisch sehr nah dran sind an
dem kreml die auch unterstützt werden
natürlich mit einer als an den bund
letzten bundestagswahlkampf mit mit
werbung usw aber ich glaube philipp
hatten ganz guten punkt und ich würde ja
noch erweitern denn wir haben ein
problem mit kremltreuen politikern in
der mitte unserer gesellschaft und der
krieg schon mal ist das krasseste
beispiel jemand der also jetzt einfach
weitermacht und der einfach sagt das ist
mir doch egal wir bleiben einfach so
aber ich möchte auch andere leute noch
einmal andere politiker und nicht in der
cdu sondern in der csu und der spd noch
einmal nennen hier die in den letzten
tagen zurück gerudert sind den letzten
tagen gesagt haben da ja sagt das haben
wir nicht erwartet was dieser putin
macht und so und ich möchte
herausstellen wie unglaublich
scheinheilig das ist und ich möchte da
einfach mal drei leute nennen wenn es in
ordnung ist zum einen du hast du schon
gesagt manuela schwesig die noch vor
einem jahr für eine umweltstiftung von
der die ganze welt wusste ist keine
umweltstiftung sondern einen ort zudem
zwei stiftung hier einfach gesagt hat
ich nehme mir 20 millionen euro von
gazprom und macht damit in politik macht
damit innenpolitik macht damit angeblich
umweltpolitik eigentlich ging es nur an
die amerika politik zu machen denn wer
sich genau angeguckt hat worum es
dagegen in dieser stiftung das war
nichts anderes als die sanktionen zu
umgehen der amerikaner dafür wurde das
genommen und da wurden tatsächlich auch
schiffe mit gecovert diese frau die
jetzt vor ein paar tagen sagt ja dass
das weiß ich gar nicht wie das passieren
konnte diese stiftung report aufgelöst
na ja der war sehr gut denn dann macht
das ja ganz schlimm wo ich mich frage
hat ihr das zum ersten mal gesehen ihrem
leben ja wir haben auch von t-online
beispielsweise gehört die online welt
haben herausgefunden dass sie sich immer
wieder mit herrn schröder getroffen hat
dass sie immer wieder geheimtreffen
hatte mit mit ihrem alten parteikader
und und dort sich abgesprochen hat wie
kann man das machen wie kann man diese
diese pipeline am besten herr schröder
arbeitet für die pipeline bis vor kurzem
erst seit zwei tagen pleite das finde
ich sehr schön noch zum 2 gibt es nicht
mehr die ag
trotzdem die dieses ganz plötzliche
zweites beispiel will ich noch mal sagen
damit wir auch da ein bisschen weg
kommen aus dieser spd ecke ist herr
söder markus söder hat im letzten und
vorletzten jahr während der chorakademie
versucht wahlkampf zu machen und
versucht russland politik zu machen
indem er diese sputnik fünf impfstoff
der von vornherein als russland benutzt
wurde als als mittel der hybriden
kriegsführung freunde haben hingekriegt
feinde haben wir nicht gekriegt was
dagegen gesagt hat warum sofort werde
den gemachte die wie die italiener
beispielsweise der hat das ganz großes
gekriegt und jeder hat mitgemacht also
diese firma dies publik fünf hergestellt
hat hat niemals auch nur annähernd genug
unterlagen geliefert studien geliefert
damit dass in der eu an gebracht werden
konnte und erinnert und gesagt er muss
jetzt schnell eine entscheidung her und
wir brauchen das und hat nach bayern
eine fabrik geholt also eine russische
firma eine mit start wurde eine ziemlich
verbunden firma die in bayern das
produzieren sollte hat natürlich auch
gesagt am ersten tag des krieges es wird
kein sputnik 5 bei uns produziert ich
habe das gemacht an bayern wir immer so
ist das hätte man jahre vorher machen
können und jeder hat es gewusst aber er
hat gewartet bis tausende ukrainer
sterben mussten um das zu machen und das
dritte und letzte und dann bin ich auch
fertig und dann können wir darüber noch
mal diskutieren ist ja platzeck auch
herr platzeck ehemalige spd chef
matthias platzeck und mindest präsident
von brandenburg hat vor zwei tagen
gesagt also ich bin nicht mehr chef des
deutsch russischen forums weil was der
herr putin macht das habe ich nicht von
ihm erwartet und da muss ich sagen wie
naiv kann man sein wie blauäugig kammern
seien auch herr platzeck wie frau
schwesig seit jahren geld des kreml an
die gottschalk auf stiftung die
staatliche stiftung des kreml
kofinanziert seine sitzung in moskau in
berlin in potsdam usw und gibt dem
deutsch russischen forum geld damit
diese ganzen politiker dort eingeladen
werden können und diese drei habe ich
jetzt mal genannt und die sind aber nur
stellvertretend für eine politische
elite in deutschland die seit jahren so
tut als wäre das alles nicht so schlimm
ja da war mal die krim jahr da war mal
syrien da wurde mal 7000 leute zu tode
gekommen in aleppo alles nicht so
wichtig aber jetzt macht's plötzlich
klick und sie sagen jaja das wussten wir
alles nicht und ich sagte dass dieser
satz davon habe er nichts gewusst der
ist in deutschland leider sehr berühmt
und berüchtigt und der gilt einfach
nicht mehr
sie haben lange ja den kanzlerin beraten
erst mal ist mal nach diesem statement
von dir julian sehr geplättet see ist
die deutsche politik so schlimm sind die
deutschen politiker so schlimm dass man
ihn diese vorwürfe machen sollte
naja das thema russland ist schon ein
schwieriges thema nicht ich war ja auch
bei gesprächen dabei mit putin und die
kanzlerin war ja auch während des der
ganzen ukraine krise auch nach der
annexion der krim war sie so die haupt
vermittlerin eigentlich des westens mit
mit putin und wir konnten damals dankbar
sein dass es so jemanden gab weil putin
hätte mit keinem anderen gesprochen weil
er kam nahm auch keinen anderen ernst
und gerade in der phase war es wichtig
dass wir mit angela merkel so ein
sprachrohr hatten ich habe das selber
auch erlebt das war auch faszinierend
wenn sie da auf internationalen
konferenzen dann plötzlich auch mit dem
russisch sprach konnte einfach in seiner
sprache reden und eher umgekehrt ja auch
deutsch und
das ist natürlich ein problem aber sie
wir müssen halt gucken jetzt
perspektivisch wir haben fehler gemacht
grobe fehler gemacht spätestens seit der
annexion der krim hätte man besonders ja
zum beispiel bei der annexion der krim
nicht knallhart zu sagen das ist jetzt
die rote linie und jetzt
machen wir das alte system also den
alten kontakt mit putin sohn nicht
weiter wie die geschilderten beispiel
zeigen hat man das ja nicht gemacht wenn
ich mal hat auch nicht die richtigen
schlussfolgerungen gezogen nach der
annexion der krim für die sicherheits
und verteidigungspolitik das macht man
jetzt seit ein paar tagen recht
dazwischen ist ja auch viel passiert nun
ist man immer klüger wenn man aus dem
rathaus kommt das stimmt auch aber
das sind schon aus heutiger sicht fehler
denn er hat ja die ukraine regelrecht
überfallen vor ein paar tagen und das
ist ja auch ein kulturbruch das ist eine
richtige zäsur auch in europa und das
hat ja seit 45 nicht mehr gegeben wenn
man so will aber erst an warum hat man
diese fehler gemacht warum hat man da
die rote linie nicht gezogen die
kanzlerin gerade noch so berühmte für
das sie angeblich alles vom ende her
denkt und das ende ihrer russlandpolitik
ist die fast vernichtung der ukraine
können sie uns erklären warum die
bundeskanzlerin diesen schweren fehler
begangen hat und offenbar putin nicht
gebremst hat obwohl doch alles für alle
fakten vor ihr auf dem tisch lagen naja
ich glaube so einfach ist das nicht also
sie hat auch was nato mitgliedschaft der
ukraine anbelangt da oft bremspedal
getreten also seit diesen berühmten
nato-gipfel 2008 in bukarest ich war
selber mit dabei und sie hat damals
gesagt leute wir sollten das nicht
überstürzen weil es damals auch aus
ihrer sicht für die ukraine schwer
gewesen wäre weil sie innenpolitisch
damit auch ein problem hatte es gab
damals nicht nur befürworter
das hat sich heute alles geändert und
nach der annexion der krim mit
sicherheit auch aber das sind natürlich
entwicklungen auf der zeitachse wir
wissen heute mehr man konnte damals
nicht ahnen dass er die ukraine einfach
überfällt rech und heute ist es
allerdings so wo man auch in die zukunft
schauen müssen so krass das ist was da
im moment abläuft
die nato ist nicht willens einen krieg
zu führen die amerikaner sind es auch
nicht dass muss man ganz klar sagen
und dieser versprecher von biden in
washington der war für mich schon sehr
sehr eindeutig wo ist umging bei meiner
in kirchens durch durch russland schaut
man nicht so genau hin das muss man sich
mal das waren für mich eine freudsche
fehlleistung weil damit wurde eigentlich
signalisiert also die claims zwischen
washington moskau sind abgesteckt und er
kann das eben machen was er jetzt im
moment macht nicht in dieser krassen
form aber man muss einfach sehen wie
kommen wir da raus ohne in einen krieg
und damit in einen weltkrieg zu gehen
wir kommen da nur raus wenn wir
irgendwann wieder mit diesem menschen
reden trotzdem ganzen wasser gemacht hat
oder er wird weggeputzt von seinen
oligarchen die haben sich ja auch jetzt
gegen ihn ausgesprochen es steht ja auch
massiv unter druck durch dieses ganze
sanktionspaket das ist zwar nicht
kriegsentscheidend aber es ist schwer er
steht auch innenpolitisch unter druck
weil die russische bevölkerung leidet
ihr mit der rubel der stürzt ins ins
abseits china selbst hat gesagt also das
ist nicht unser verbündeter was er da
macht damit wollen wir nichts zu tun
haben und hat heute nicht mit ihnen
gebetet vom genau was ist schon genau
und das ist eine schwierige situation
und jetzt müssen wir gucken wie gehen
wir damit weiter um ja wir können wir
können sagen ja okay
wir machen ihnen das leben zur hölle er
kann ja nicht so leicht rein gehen wie
ich in der sendung lassen wir philipp
einmal darauf jetzt reagieren dass er
auch seine reaktion auf die erklärung
natürlich von ihnen herr fahrt geben
darf
die frage nämlich umtreibt die hat der
vater angesprochen ist
wäre die nato den bereit ein
nato-mitglied zu verteidigen wir sehen
jetzt wie die vokale zwar hier und da
mit waffen unterstützt wird aber wie ich
finde noch bei weitem nicht genug was
wenn putin als nächstes sich estland
holen will und wer dann die nato sagen
oh ja es ist ein nato-mitglied und
abholen oder was auch immer und dann
eingreifen oder wird die nahezu sagen
ach das ist ja nur so ein kleines land
wollen wir wirklich den großen krieg mit
russland da würde mich sehr
interessieren was die runde dazu sagt
frau möchten sie antworten auf der
piazza ich glaube wir haben das problem
damit wie wir überhaupt einen
konfliktfreien wir sprechen über die
nato über den konflikt zwischen nato und
russland aber eigentlich das was wir
heute erleben das ist ein konflikt
zwischen dem restlichen system das heißt
zwischen dem demokratischen system und
einem autoritären system und eigentlich
wie der kampf um die ukraine sozusagen
ausgehen wird wird auch unsere zukunft
dar und davon abhängen heute ich glaube
die nato und auch mitglieder der
europäischen union
nato-staaten weil ich so müssen sich
überlegen wie können sie vielleicht
werden durch unkonventionelle wege oder
so sich überlegen wie können sie die
ukraine unterstützen sei es zum beispiel
wenn wir ihr war auch diese
flugverbotszone sprechen wir wissen auch
haben uns auch mit militärischen
experten darüber unterhalten dass
vielleicht dass es nicht möglich ist für
die ganze ukraine die flugverbotszone
einzuführen aber gleichzeitig müssen wir
uns gedanken machen was würde passieren
wenn zum beispiel einer rakete ein
atomkraftwerk in der ukraine
treffen wird und die atomare in grenzen
die die atomaren gefahren haben keine
grenzen und ich glaube war sehr
schwierig ist auch in deutschland wir
haben das gefühl manchmal ja die
sanktionen sind eingeführt und so wir
haben unser bestes geleistet aber wir
schauen nicht weiter der konflikt würden
nicht aufhören was wir schon in der
ukraine erleben dass die zivilisten
erschossen werden und ich glaube das
dürfen wir nicht tolerieren und ich
frage mich auch wo ist die schmerzgrenze
wie viele menschen sollen in der ukraine
leben damit wir dann sagen wir können
dann eingreifen was der ukrainische
präsident jetzt vor kurzem gemacht hat
er hat eine internationale legion jetzt
gegründet das heißt ausländer aus
anderen staaten dürfen jetzt der
ukrainischen armee anschließen
und ich glaube durch solche nicht
konservativer wege versucht man auch
andere anwalt an eigene seite zu ziehen
und damit die ukraine diesen trick nicht
verliert vor allem das merkt man ja auch
hier in der runde die stammzuschauer von
48 werden es bemerkt haben es war glaube
ich das erste mal dass wir zwei thesen
in einer zusammenhang weil philipp und
du er war so ein ähnliches thema für
heute ausgesucht hat julian wo wir es
mal 2000 schon auf einmal hatten ich
finde das zeigt so sehr wie enttäuscht
man auch selbst als deutsche von
politikern ist ich zum beispiel eine
sehr von gerhard schröder muss ich
einfach sagen mich enttäuscht dass sehr
dass er 407 407
hunderttausend euro im jahr erhält vom
deutschen staat und dann ja eigentlich
ja gestern hat mein kollege der politik
stefan schäfer gesagt er sollte nach
moskau fliegen ich sehe dass
mittlerweile auch wirklich ehrlich so
jeden fall kein geld mehr vom deutschen
staat einstreichen aber was auch fakt
ist und da würde ich gerne bei fragen
wie sich der deutsche staat verhalten
soll wenn man auf die energien blickt
paul also energietechnische sind wir ja
nun von diesen despoten abhängig was
sollen wir denn eigentlich machen jetzt
als deutscher staat
ja vielleicht ganz aktuelle nachrichten
die sich gerade bestätigt haben frau
monique hat es ja angesprochen wie sehr
russland auf die zivile bevölkerung hier
zielt und wir hören dass die explosionen
die wir ungefähr vor 30 minuten gehört
haben offenbar in richtung eines wasser
heizwerks gerichtet waren das müssen wir
gleich noch mal weiter recherchieren
aber das sind jetzt die ukrainische
meldungen das bedeutet dass
möglicherweise teile der stadt das in
teilen weiteren teilen der stadt das
warme wasser ausfallen wird unabhängig
davon ob es dann möglicherweise auch
opfer gegeben hat diese meldungen sind
noch nicht ganz klar aber man sieht auch
in dem minuten wo wir hier diskutieren
findet putins krieg weiterstadt was die
energieabhängigkeit angeht muss man
einmal ganz klar sagen dass wir das so
viele jahre mitgemacht haben war einfach
wahnsinnig naiv und hat unserem land
geschadet dass man sich so abhängig
gemacht hat weil es wäre ja nicht nötig
gewesen und ich bin kein anhänger der
atomenergie persönlich geprägt durch
debatten
der der vergangenen jahrzehnte aber
dennoch ist es sicherlich etwas worüber
man in deutschland wieder nachdenken
muss geradezu dazu zählen aber auch
andere
energiequellen wir können nicht sagen
wir wollen kein russisches gas mehr und
dann unsere bevölkerung sagen gut dann
müsste die nächsten jahre bis der
präsident putin weg ist frieren das geht
ja nicht von daher müssen wir uns da
gedanken machen und vor allem so bitter
das ist energie wird ab ende eher teurer
werden wahrscheinlich viel teurer werden
und da muss es dann auch in einer ampel
koalition
denke ich die möglichkeit geben
denjenigen zu helfen die nicht so viel
geld im geldbeutel haben um sich diese
energie zu leisten weil was würden uns
nicht ertragen können sind bilder von
vielen frierenden menschen weil die
heizungen ausgefallen ist aber paul also
du sagst du bist kein großer befürworter
von von kernenergie und natürlich die
aktuelle kernenergiepolitik wurde von
der großen koalition beschlossen dass du
mir nicht vergessen aber ich habe mich
doch sehr gewundert als ich gestern
unseren energieminister jahren habe ich
gehört habe der gesagt hat ja also so
wie das jetzt auch nicht dazu ich bin
durch genau das wollte so wie es jetzt
aussieht müssen wir vielleicht die kohle
länger laufen lassen will ich sage jetzt
kohle jetzt ganz im ernst also wir haben
doch gerade drei nuklearkraft werke die
nicht von heute auf morgen wieder
hochgefahren werden können der platz ist
auch aus gemerkt haben diese energie
brauchen wir und auch diese dieses
argument immer zu sagen ja das wird aber
teurer dann und so ich habe jetzt gerade
mein gasanbieter hat nach einem jahr mir
natürlich gerade gekündigt und hat ihr
neues angebot gemacht
340 prozent 340 prozent
preissteigerungen ja von 5,5 cent auf 15
19 pro kilowattstunde und das ist die
realität nicht von mir sondern von allen
wir sehen das seit und das ist immer
dass das volk sei trotz stream 2 fertig
ist seit august letzten jahres meldet
sich bei uns check24 und andere
vergleichsportale und sagen es ist
verrückt ja jetzt wo diese fertig ist
dann schalten die russen nacheinander
zuerst so kann ein netzwerk aus nichts
mehr extra gebucht dann die ja mal
halblang seit dezember ausgeschaltet wir
haben nur noch 19 1 unsere einzige
energiequelle sind völlig abhängig davon
und auch da muss ich sagen frau merkel
hat noch im dezember gesagt wir sind
nicht abhängig von russischem gas das
ist wahnsinnig wenn ich das höre kurz
danach war das argument ja wir sind
total abhängig vom russischen gas und
deshalb können wir jetzt keine weiteren
sanktionen beschließen
also da muss ich mich erst wunder muss
auch sagen
die die kernenergie die wir da haben und
die uns zur verfügung steht und die in
vielen vielen anderen europäischen
ländern sicher angewandt wird dass wir
die nicht wieder ausbauen dass wir die
nicht wieder zurückfahren und dieser
diese fehlentscheidung von 2011
rückgängig machen das ist mir nicht klar
denn ich sehe jetzt nochmal eine
verdreifachung seiner gasrechnung und
ich habe kein muss zufrieren ganz
ehrlich und deshalb bin ich auch für
andere energie erfahren sie gedacht dass
sie im deutschen fernsehen mal so ein
plädoyer für die kernenergie noch hören
oder es hätten alle linien gefallen
denkverbote sind weg der diskurs ist
wieder offen nein also ich hätte ich
hätte das nicht gedacht und das ist
schon sehr krass und ich muss aber sagen
natürlich hat das einen hat das den
rationalen und das ist schon ganz klar
und das zeigt aber auch wie schwierig es
jetzt die regierung hat die müssen ja
mit einer ganzen menge von maximen
prinzipien brechen einfach und das ist
ja ein punkt recht die die kernkraft
wurde ja regelrecht verteufelt in
deutschland manche ausländische
beobachter sagen ja das ist diese
irrationale seite der deutschen von
heute die sind gegen kernkraft und zwar
ganz massiv kein anderes land der welt
nur massiv ja ja und jetzt müssen wir
neu darüber nachdenken das geht ja auch
in die anderen felder rhein in der
sicherheitspolitik waffenexporte in ein
kriegsgebiet zack es läuft nicht dann
die nukleare teilhabe jetzt durch die
atomare bedrohung ja auch von von putin
das ist weg vom fenster ja ich
wahrscheinlich werden wir 35 kaufen und
werden die news in deutschland lagern
und wir transportieren sie dann im
bedarfsfall dahin wo sie wo sie
hingehören oder drohen damit an das wäre
unvorstellbar noch vor einer woche da
hätte jeder politiker also gerade der
grünen gesagt das findet nicht statt 100
milliarden für die bundeswehr
unvorstellbar also dass man sieht da
haben der ganze koalitionsvertrag in
ganz wichtigen aussagen der als
makulatur
regeln dieser aggression vorn weil es
mich und das mich interessieren
was mich interessieren würde was ihre
meinung dazu ist wie die kanzlerin wenn
sie noch im amt wäre also nehmen wir an
sie hätte noch eine fünfte amt sondern
angestrebt und wäre jetzt noch kanzlerin
und wäre in dieser krise erstens wie
würde sie sich gegenüber der ukraine
verhalten und zweitens glauben sie dass
die kanzlerin bereit wäre zu sagen die
lage ist jetzt anders ich habe fehler
gemacht deswegen machen wir jetzt wieder
atomenergie
ja das ist eine echt gute frage ich weiß
es nicht ich weiß es nicht ich kann das
nicht beantworten was sie machen würde
aber es ist sicherlich auch teil dieser
strategie von putin gewesen zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt das zu machen ich denke der
weiß da ist eine neue deutsche regierung
aus drei parteien die sind müssen sich
erst warm machen die haben viele
probleme intern mit auch mit ihren
themen usw und da gibt es den
französischen präsidenten der ist hat
zwar die eu ratspräsidentschaft aber der
wird im april gewählt keiner weiß ob er
bleibt nicht dann gibt es einen
schwachen amerikanischen präsidenten und
im hintergrund ein donald trump der
vielleicht in drei jahren wieder kommt
und all das spielte sicherlich auch mit
und hat seinen entschluss begünstigt
wenn überhaupt es jetzt durchzuziehen
was er jetzt gerade macht das muss man
auch sehen also diese frage was würde
merkel machen in der situation kann ich
wirklich nicht mehr beantworten sie ist
nicht mehr im amt
aber dazu muss ich sagen dass wenn wir
jetzt über die reaktion des westens
sprechen dann war das schon sehr
einheitlich und der westen hat sich von
sehr guten seite eigentlich gezeigt das
einzige und ich glaube der russische
präsident hat schon damit gerechnet dass
nämlich der westen jetzt die schwäche
zeigen wird was mich ich glaube noch mal
würde ich nochmal zurück auf den punkt
warum die ja so naiv waren ich glaube
was wir immer unterschätzt haben die
öffentliche meinung in deutschland und
journalisten auch über die annexion
betrieben berichtet haben wir hatten
damals schon so erleben so eine krise
der begriffe wir wussten auch nicht wie
sollen wir die russischen soldaten
bezeichnen wir hatten immer so grüne
männchen bezeichnet wird das hat alles
einen einfluss auf die öffentliche
meinung und auch dies und das prägt den
diskurs und dementsprechend der diskurs
hat auch einen einfluss auf die politik
der unterschied den wir jetzt erleben in
diesem krieg wir wissen ganz genau mit
welchen begriffen
dieses vorgehen von russland bezeichnen
sollen und ich glaube für die zukunft
das ist unglaublich wichtig zu verstehen
welche begriffe wir nutzen um ein
verbrechen zu bezeichnen davor ich
glaube hat schon der russische präsident
auch angst und ich bin sehr froh dass
wir jetzt ganz klare begriffe haben um
dann den den überfall setzt seinen
russland auf die ukraine mit seinem
bezeichnen ein weiteres beispiel dafür
vielleicht unter sich bis heute es wird
immer noch von prorussischen
separatisten glück gesprochen das ist
dieses fantasie bord was man sich
mannomann ausgedacht hat und was aber
machen die öffentlich-rechtlichen bis
heute durchgehalten wird bis heute in
den aktuellen berichten russischer
soldaten an der seite von prorussischen
separatisten usw so genannten versichere
separatisten man weiß seit jahren dass
sie aus moskau finanziert aus moskau
bewaffnet um mittlerweile die anführer
russische staatsbürger sind und
mitglieder der putin partei einiges
russland sind also mehr rosig geht gar
nicht und trotzdem hat man dieses sind
sperrigen begriff das ist was ganz
differenziertes und dann muss man genau
hingucken und das sollte man nicht den
putin anlasten bis heute und wo ich noch
das problem sehe dass wir immer denken
dass die russisch gelenkten medien
journalisten sind wir sind nicht mehr
journalisten und wir versuchen durch
verschiedene talkshows immer so
verschiedene meinungen darzustellen das
ist keine pluralität wir haben menschen
die heute als instrumenten des krieges
genutzt werden und diejenigen die jetzt
den krieg in der ukraine verfolgen
wissen ganz genau wie videos da
dargestellt werden wie lügen über lügen
verbreitet werden und da ich glaube das
ist auch eine herausforderung für
journalisten
und auch für die rolle der journalistin
und ich frage mich wie hier wird das
weitergehen und wickeln vielleicht
sollten wir auch die rolle der
journalisten heute nur ein definieren
das würde ich jetzt sehr sehr gerne
debattieren denn auch im journalismus
passieren ja auch manchmal fehler die
hätte man jetzt auch mal debattieren
können wir geben aber jetzt eine ganz
kurze unterbrechung an dieser stelle
ganz herzlichen dank an philipp pfaff
nicht nur für seine these sondern vor
allem für seine arbeit eine reporter
dasein in der ukraine ganz herzlichen
dank und liebe grüße nach lemberg
philipp
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zurück liebe
zuschauern gegeben direkt weiter zur
frau mary
wie wir schon jetzt diskutiert haben ich
glaube wir erleben heute wirklich einen
und residenz losen krieg das ist ein
angriffskrieg seit dem zweiten weltkrieg
und dieser krieg hat drei dimensionen
weil wir sehr oft in unseren der warte
nur über die militärische dimension
sprechen die erste mit dem ensi und das
ist die militärische ich glaube herr
putin hat auch damit gar nicht gerechnet
dass ich den trainer seinen großen
widerstand leisten wird es gibt auch
informationen das eigentlich geht im
ersten tag schon eingenommen werden
sollte wir sehen auch sehr viele
soldaten die jetzt russische soldaten
dient und kräne
sterben nach offiziellen angaben des
ukrainischen
verteidigungsministeriums sind das circa
6000 soldaten die gestorben sind
ich glaube etwas wovor ich persönlich ja
so ein bisschen angst habe dass der
krieg dauert schon lange für putins ich
glaube vorstellungen und in zukunft
können wir nur damit rechnen dass die
angriffe auf die zivilbevölkerung noch
ein brutaler werden die zweite dimension
das ist nämlich die
betriebs die cyber-angriffe die
noch vor dem offenen krieg erfolgten die
cyber angriffe allerdings was ich glaube
schon positiv ist dass die ukrainische
regierung auch jetzt nicht schon stärker
hat dagegen vorzugehen
es wir wissen auch dass internationaler
hacker jetzt sich verein tragen und
angriffe auf das russische
verteidigungsministerium gemacht haben
und die datenbanken wurden gelegte die
kreml seite war lahmgelegt russischer
gelenkten medien wurden auch gehackt und
zum beispiel jungfischer höhener wurde
dann über
russische sender dann verbreitet und das
wird stattfinden diese cyberangriff wir
sind heute auch zeugen dieses cyber
krieg ist ich glaube der dann
stattfinden weiter stattfinden wird und
den dritten dimension das ist nämlich
propaganda aber wir reduzieren sie sehr
oft diese propaganda auf fake ist und
das ist nicht der fall ein provokantes
informationen die wir von seite russland
erleben hat zum ziel einer parallelwelt
zu schaffen und kann die menschen nicht
erreichen man sieht dass
man auch mit der russischen soldaten
sprich zum beispiel wenn sie ihre mutter
anrufen und einige sagen ja ihr kämpft
aber für die heimat oder zb hat mit
einer russischen bekannten gesprochen
und gesagt
du hast dann kann ich mit meinem vater
nicht sprechen obwohl er intelligent ist
und englisch spricht aber er glaubt
wirklich daran dass das in tschernobyl
die atomwaffen stationiert sind und dass
die ukraine eine atombombe auf moskau
werfen möchte und daher ist es für mich
ich glaube schon die frage wie werden
wir in zukunft die solchen parallelen
welten umgehen und was können wir
dagegen machen
erfahrt was sagen sie dazu sage ich
finde diese analyse absolut bestechend
weil das natürlich zeigt wie moderne
kriegführung abläuft die ist hybrid in
sicht besteht aus mehreren komponenten
ineinander übergehen und gerade jetzt im
zeitalter der digitalisierung ist gerade
dieser information warfare total also
sehr sehr stark das darf man nicht
unterschätzen
denn damit wird letztlich unser mindset
gesteuert und das was wir denken und
fühlen welche und das ist natürlich sehr
psychologisch einerseits nicht aber die
psychologischen faktoren in der modernen
kriegsführung auch die bleiben ein sehr
massives ganz ganz wichtiges instrument
der kriegsführung das ist vollkommen
klar und das machen die russen auch
genauso im cyber bereich das ist jetzt
eine neue dimension die durch die auch
die digitalisierung der land
kriegführung dazu gekommen ist die man
nicht mehr ausschließen kann die
parallel läuft und teilweise auch schon
vor dem angriff beginnen ab lief nicht
und dann gibt es diese klassische
militärische dimension wo die russen
natürlich was ihre hauptwaffensysteme
anbelangt eine massive überlegenheit
haben gegenüber der ukrainische armee
das kann man sich ausrechnen sie haben
ja auch
nachschub ohne ende das heißt sie können
personal und material noch weiter da
reinschieben das ist die militärische
dimension allerdings muss man auch sehen
zur militärischen dimension gehört auch
diese kampf moral nicht und die ist bei
den ukrainern enorm stark
dieser starke patriotismus wo ich mir
auch sage als deutscher mein gott ein
bisschen von dem könnte uns auch ganz
gut tun recht da haben wir eigentlich zu
wenig davon nicht und wo man dann sieht
dass ich diese kampfmoral wirklich so
stark sein kann dass sie selbst diese
materielle überlegenheit so ein stück
weit ausgleichen kann hebel durch ganz
gerne ganz kurz paul ronzheimer rheine
ein paar wie sehr spürst du diesen
patriotismus und den kampfgeist in kiew
ja dieser patriotismus es wahnsinnig zu
spüren und ist emotional und bei jedem
aufgeladen gerade eben als ich mit den
klitschko brüdern zusammen war da merkt
man dass in jeder pore sozusagen ja die
beiden riesen die dort stehen und sagen
nein wir bleiben hier sie kämpfen weiter
die geschlossenheit im land und darüber
sprechen
das ist jede minute los gehen kann und
die noch einmal einfach erklären wie
sehr die ukraine an ihrem land hängen
und dieses land nicht aufgeben werden
von da ich stimme ich da total zu dass
das so ist und auch mich beeindruckt
dieser patriotismus aber frau mendig hat
aus meiner sicht einen sehr wichtigen
punkt aufgeworfen ich weiß nicht ob am
ende die
militärische oder auch der patriotismus
diesen krieg entscheidet sondern man
muss es ja realistisch betrachten
irgendwann würde wladimir putin bender
das gesamte militär nimmt das er hat und
ihnen die sanktion völlig egal sind wird
er in welcher form auch immer kiew sehr
wahrscheinlich einnehmen können das kann
viel länger dauern als er das plan aber
wenn er mit allen waffen draufgeht dia
hat und aus tier sagen wir ein neues
aleppo macht dann wird er es irgendwann
schaffen davon gehe ich zumindest aus
deswegen ist die frage um so wichtiger
was passiert mit den informationen mit
der wahrheit die wahrheit was ist
wahrheit was ist lüge und wie sehr
schafft putin ist weiterhin aus wahrheit
aus lüge wahrheit zu machen und das
schafft er immer noch viel zu viel wir
haben zwar proteste gesehen aber es sind
keine massenproteste wir erleben wenn
unser kollege peter tiede dort in
russland unter fix ist und dort bilder
aus kiew zeigt dann sagen die menschen
nein das ist gelogen die bilder stimmen
nicht das sind nazis über all das
überhaupt diese mehr der nazis der
ukrainische nazis sich seit 2014
erhalten kann ich weiß noch als ich das
erste mal gehört habe auf dem majdan und
vitali klitschko zu mir sagte guck mal
die erzählen wieder ich sei ein nazi und
ich dachte nur so ja keine ahnung aber
was ist das für ein bullshit ja aber
dass sich sozusagen daraus dieses diese
macht entwickelt hat die diese
geschichte oder diese propaganda trägt
und ein krieg kann putin gewinnen aber
er muss vor allem die propaganda
gewinnen damit er diesen krieg verkaufen
kann und da müsste ich uns schon die
frage stellen wie kann das passieren wir
wollen ja keine propaganda machen wir
wollen wahrheitsgetreu berichten wir
wollen fakten zeigen aber in russland
werden diese fakten eben nicht gezeigt
und da würde mich tatsächlich auch eine
militärische perspektive zu der frage
interessieren welche art der
kriegsführung für das ergebnis am ende
vielleicht sogar entscheidende ist ich
wollte allerdings noch mal darauf
eingehen es geht nicht darum dass er
weiß jetzt propaganda betreibt auf gar
keinen fall was wir nicht gemacht haben
ihm auch deutschen fernsehen wir haben
zum beispiel puten nicht so richtig
sprechen lassen oder alle diese
propagandisten usw die hass sprache ich
glaube das haben wir in der rede von
bonin jetzt erlebte die wurde
gedolmetscht und wir haben das unter der
haut gespürt man muss die menschen
sprechen lassen um die anderen können
darüber urteilen und wir haben zuviel
interpretiert und das ist jetzt der
deswegen möchte ich noch mal betonen gar
keine propaganda betreiben aber man muss
sich überlegen wie können wir dann
rechtliches das wollte ich die noch gar
nicht das wollte ich ihnen das wollte
ich ihnen gar nicht unterstellen oder
das habe ich auch gar nicht so
interpretiert meine frage war er wie
damit umzugehen sein soll dass in
russland die dinge weiterhin so
dargestellt werden wie sie dargestellt
werden und das bedeutet dass immer noch
eine so große vielzahl glaubt
wie sie ja auch da über ihren vater
berichtet haben dass da im westen
schlimmes passiert ja das ist ich glaube
sehr auch gute frage an die experten zu
sagen die sich eben mir im it bereich
auskennen aber was mich überrascht hat
dass zum beispiel diese hacker auch
geschafft haben für eine gewisse zeit
ihre bilder über gelenkten medien zu
verbreiten das ist die frage ich glaube
so eher an die leute können sie wirklich
zum beispiel zukunft solche über solche
medien auch ihre informationen
verbreiten und auch jeder sozialen
medien aber da habe ich ganz ruhig weiß
die zeit drängt aber ganz kurz nochmal
wir reden über propaganda und wir ihn
die ganze zeit über russland und ukraine
können wir bitte auch bei uns hingucken
ich möchte daran erinnern dass vier
staatliche russische medien ihren sitz
in berlin haben und auf deutsche
berichten ja das ist einmal sputnik das
nennt sich jetzt s n a das ist einmal
rtl de das war für hat die deutsche
nennt sich also auch noch andauern und
das is red fish und das ist apple diese
große video agentur die bestimmen den
diskurs wir haben schon oft auch bei uns
sogar bild die position gehabt dass ich
gesagt habe jetzt müssen wir eigentlich
von rugby einkaufen wir müssen den kreml
finanzieren weil die diese mittel
aufbringen dass sie überall sind
beispiele julian assange vor der
botschaft in london waren die zum
beispiel und viele andere sachen und das
ist unglaublich gefährlich das geht bei
uns vor der haustür ab aktuell nur so
dass es auch einmal gesagt es klappt wie
gegen
rappi und rt also diese russische
propaganda seiner ging vier artikel die
ich geschrieben habe also auch dieser
realistischen putin es muss dieser läge
die dass diese propagandisten uns
gerichtlich verbieten wollen die
wahrheit zu sagen und das geht in
unserem rechtsstaat ja dass das ist
wahnsinn insofern alles gut wenn man
nach moskau guckt wenn man nach kirkuk
aber bitte nicht nach berlin und
deutschland gucken wo die russische
propaganda extrem aktiv ist erfahrt
jetzt machen wir ihre these und reden
über die zeitenwende eine epochale
zeitenwende ja die app hoch halle
zeitenwende in der wir uns
sicherheitspolitisch befinden besteht
einfach darin dass man erstmalig seit
1945 die situation hat dass ein land ein
nachbarland überfallen wird
und das hat natürlich immense
auswirkungen letztlich auf unsere
sicherheitspolitik das ist eine zäsur
wie 9 und 80 damals ende des kalten
krieges und heute ist es eben so dass
wir damit in eine komplett neue zeit
gehen wir müssen uns überlegen wie
stellt sich die nato jetzt auf wir haben
ja damals in den 90er jahren die senator
russland grund aktie gemacht mit
russland wir haben geregelt dass wir in
den osteuropäischen bündnis
ländern keine permanenten streitkräfte
stationieren rotierende verbände auch
nicht so ausgestattet wie es optimal
wäre für die vorne verteidigung das
alles steht zur disposition
wir wissen ja auch nicht was putin
danach macht nicht es steht nur fest
dass wir in den appetit auf mehr
unbedingt nehmen müssen wenn die
baltischen staaten zb waren auch mal bei
sowjetrepubliken haben auch russische
minderheit und er könnte mit dem
gleichen drehbuch wie in georgien mit
südossetien nach asien mit dollars in
der ukraine könnte er sehr schnell auch
mit lettland operieren und wie
verhindern wir dass das ist die große
frage und wie ist der deutsche beitrag
breche wir haben erstmalig für die
bundeswehr eine wahnsinnige
finanzspritze nicht die bundeswehr ist
faktisch aber nicht einsatzbereit wenn
wir in einer situation heute wären wie
die ukraine wir konnten uns gar nicht
wehren und ich sehe auch nicht den
deutschen patriotismus und die kämpfer
die bereit wären in den untergrund zu
gehen und so einen konflikt
durchzuziehen das heißt wir müssen
unseren mindset also komplett ändern und
glaube das ist ganz entscheidend neben
den ganzen materiellen dingen die wir
jetzt umsetzen müssen um die bundeswehr
einsatz bereit zu kriegen aber das wird
auch jahre dauern und das ist wirklich
eine ganz krasse zäsur in der wir uns
befinden eine zeitenwende weder
bundeskanzler scholz auch richtigerweise
sagt
ich habe mich glaube soll er auch
praktische fragen sie weil in der
ukraine wird sehr oft über den schutz
des himmels gesprochen und so kann zum
beispiel sagen eigentlich auf dem lande
können wir selber dann die russische
soldaten bekämpfen sehen sie die
möglichkeit das vielleicht durch die
nato oder vielleicht auch andere staaten
möglich wäre den beitrag zu dem schutz
in das hinein zu zeigen zu leisten damit
die raketen nicht einfach auf zivile
objekte
abgeschossen werden ja das ist eine
frage jetzt auch in dir diskutiert wurde
die die der
ukrainische präsident ja auch brachte
mit dem verbot flugverbotszone das ist
natürlich schwierig wir haben die
angewandt auf dem balkan im irak und
das kann man eigentlich nur machen wenn
man als eine starke militärkoalition ist
gegenüber einem wesentlich schwächeren
herausforderung oder gegner der ein paar
flieger hat ein paar hubschrauber hat
aber hier haben wir russland als
weltmacht das heißt der einstieg in so
eine flugverbotszone konsequent
betrachtet wäre der einstieg in einen
krieg recht und das ist genau der punkt
wo ich selber drüber nachdenke wir
wollen offensichtlich ja nicht diesen
kriegs konflikt diesen dritten weltkrieg
und diesen atome krieg mit russland das
ist glaube ich einhellige meinung der
aller nato partner wird einerseits
solidarisch mit der ukraine
wir wollen auch helfen wir wollen nicht
in den krieg rein und das ist so ein
bisschen schwierig möchten auch die
abschreckungsstrategie
funktioniert ja noch nur wenig
glaubwürdig machen kann dass ich auch
zum krieg bereit bin wenn der andere
weiß krieg ist ausgeschlossen dann ist
man ein abschreckungs wert gleich null
welche andererseits ist es
wahrscheinlich rational nachvollziehbar
vernünftig dass man nicht damit in einem
dritten weltkrieg rutscht das ist genau
das problem und das dilemma und was
putin anbelangt natürlich auch wenn ich
am ende dann doch das ganze regeln muss
was er da jetzt macht in der ukraine
da muss ich irgendwann ab einem
bestimmten zeitpunkt auch bereit sein
mit ihm wieder zu reden
moshe dayan hat das mal gemacht gesagt
den ich sehr schätze
toller israelischer general der auch ein
super außenminister war er hat mal
gesagt wenn du frieden willst reicht es
nicht aus mit deinen freunden zu reden
du musst mit deinem feind reden welche
und wir müssen diese option ich bin kein
cannabis meint man muss stärke zeigen
knallharte stärke grenzen aufzeigen aber
wann stellen muss ließen diesen aspekt
offen halten sonst sind wir im krieg
eine einzige zwischenfrage dann würde
ich gleich auch noch mal in folge wie
wir denn mit den feinen sprechen können
glauben sie das ist jetzt wieder ein
wortspiel ein was wäre gewesen wenn
spiel wenn frau merkel noch kanzlerin
wäre bei der thematik abschreckungs
stärke zeigen dass putin den krieg
gewagt hätte ich bin mir ich bin mir da
nicht sicher ich glaube es hat ihm den
job aus seiner sicht erleichtert dass
sie nicht mehr da war denn sie hat ihm
schon den marsch geblasen das hat sie
bei anderen dingen auch gemacht und ich
habe das ja oft bei gesprächen erlebt
dass er sie schon sehr
respektiert hat also und ein stück weit
auch
akzeptiert hat so wie sie war trotz der
ganzen gegensätze die sie auch hatte und
sie hat ihm schon das leben ziemlich
schwer gemacht und hat ihm schon gezeigt
was sie von seinem ganzen aktionen
hielten ich aber sie hat trotzdem diese
gesprächskanäle gehabt und ich halte das
so schwer dass im moment fällt also wir
brauchen beides das ist letztlich auch
das gesamte rational der nato seit dem
bestehen gewesen dass wir immer gesagt
haben setzt auf abschreckung und stärke
auf härte und hier um nicht weiter und
gleichzeitig auf die bereitschaft zum
dialog und das müssen wir machen dann
werden wir den dialog wegnehmen das ende
des dialogs ist der beginn des krieges
war wie siehst du das ende des dialogs
dialog mit den feinden wie es das
derzeit aktuelle möglich das fragen sich
auch wirklich viele
ich heiße für sehr illusorisch leider
natürlich wäre es gut wenn es
verhandlungen gebe aber erstens bleibt
und ist putin ein lügner zweitens gibt
es nichts was er auf den tisch legen
kann der herzlicher festgelegt aus
seiner sicht ist die ukraine russland
wie soll man darüber verhandelt da fehlt
mir jegliche fantasie und vor allem auch
in der frage wie der ukrainische
präsident darauf reagieren soll denn
alles was tut ihn dort auf den tisch
legen würde und sie lenski
unterschreiben würde würde hier wir
haben gerade über den patriotismus
gesprochen zu einem und bürgeraufstand
führen wahrscheinlich dann zu einem
bürgerkrieg was auch immer und man
wütend werden zu recht auf seinen ski
also das ist eine wahnsinnig schwierige
situation sowohl für den ukrainischen
präsidenten als auch für das gesamte
land
und der frage wie man da rauskommt und
ich sehe momentan nicht was auf
irgendeine art von möglichkeit hindeutet
dass es zu einem schnellen frieden
kommen können
wir sind leider schon fast am ende zehn
sekunden antwort frau wenig ich glaube
wir müssen uns die frage stellen werden
wir uns damit abfinden dass der ukrainer
den reds an bord wird und die werden wir
damit leben
die werden wir damit leben und was wird
passieren wir werden auch in den
nächsten tagen hier berichten paul
sowieso den kompletten tag nicht nur bei
48 herzlichen dank an meine gäste heute
abend hier im studio an viele peter von
natürlich auch ein paar ronzheimer kiew
schönen abend und bis morgen abend
hoffentlich
[Musik]